michael pineda and his career against
the tigers has been pretty good the main
guy he has to watch out for
miguel cabrera
and the 3-2 pitch is lifted to shallow
right center field coming over his cave
on his feet calls and catches and pineda
works a one two three
opening inning averages less than three
innings he gets three innings max we'll
see if that stays the same
65 pitches top so far this year
paredes on the charge had trouble for a
moment
gets his man by a step michael fulmer
didn't have one one two three inning in
his last start he does so far today
and the 2-2 swag and a miss and down he
goes on a breaking ball take a look at
this little slider down and real real
good pitch tougher left-handed hitter to
lay off of and the 2-2 he got him strike
three if fastball beat him beltai at 92.
pineda cleans up in the second inning
after issuing the lead-off wall
bouncer left side
donaldson
over the wave one away
the o2 strike three and down goes
paredes on three pitches fourth
strikeout bringing up ryan jeffers seven
hits so far all of them singles
a drive to center field reyes going back
that ball is gone ryan jeffers with his
first big league home run
and the twins take a one-nothing lead
this ball tail back over every time you
see that catcher's glove leak back
towards the middle of the plate
this is usually the end result and
real nice swing head down drives that
ball
and now here's wade
popped up behind third
freddy's
back to the infield and
that ball drops and wade alertly goes to
second base
tough play because the third baseman
brady's was playing in
and he had to run back to the outfield
grass and actually overran it big spot
in the third twins one tigers nothing
base is loaded still one out
rosario
that is a fair ball and it hit the bag
continuing up the line wade scores
donaldson scoring they're going to wave
another runner around rooker will score
and now rosario's hung up between second
and third after clearing the bases with
a double he's tagged out
turns up willie castro he started to
come back yesterday when the tigers are
down four with a two run home run
castro goes the other way that's a base
knock candelario's gonna be waved home
tigers are on the board thanks to
candelario's two out double and then
willy castro's rbi single
ryan jeffers straight away center field
his first major league home run bats
with a runner at second
ground ball right side that's going to
be under the glove of scope right
fielder comes up throwing and it's not
in time as cave scores
so jeffers with another rbi this is the
base hit
how good has pineda been so far in this
game
he's done exactly what we're used to
seeing him do
[Applause]
said he went around on it so romine
gonna head back to the dugout
right field corner chased by cave and
whoa what a catch
jay cave leaping into the sidewall
makes a great catch to end the inning
the o2 right swinging a soft tapper off
the changeup good pitch
norris willfield whoa he almost threw it
away and candelario got it went back to
the bag and dove and touched the bag
with his glove just before rooker
crossed first base heck of a play by
jamer candelario
and a string and a miss boy
chased one in the dirt right there and
then strikeout number six
here's cabrera on a swing and a miss and
michael pineda
another three up three down any two more
strikeouts seven now this
the afternoon twin starter this year to
pitch into the seventh inning
the 2-1 sharply hit nice play by
donaldson gonzalez couldn't get it out
of his glove
the run will score they out made it
second tigers have pulled within three
three two a swing and a foul tip hung
onto by jefferson strikeout pineda
strikes out his eighth batter
tamper to third
donaldson sets
and a scoop at first by wade
a great play by lamont wade jr digging
out a low throw from donaldson and
donaldson the first to acknowledge it
twins five tigers two bases empty for
buxton
the high fly left field stewart going
back and buxton with an insurance run in
the eighth byron does not miss his pitch
a long home run out to left center
his sixth of the season and the twins
take a 6-2 lead
trying to wrap up this five-game series
[Music]
got him over the inside corner yeah
pretty good outing for rogers he struck
out the side and the twins end up
winning this series four games to one